wednesday edition pro football talk live
peter king chris sims mike florio here
with you and it's time for a little
what's more likely if you're watching on
tv you see the draft order there there's
the top ten
and the first topic for what's more
likely is based on the top ten
specifically this what is more likely
three quarterbacks get drafted in the
top ten this year or four receivers go
in the first round chris
you're first well uh okay i i mean this
one
this one i want to say this i mean both
i think are extremely like you likely
here like i think there's like almost a
slam dunk four four wide receivers are
going in the first round at least i mean
you could have might have made it six
and i still would have said that and the
quarterback thing yeah i'm definitely
all right so if i'm gonna say what's
more likely at this point i'll guess i
guess i'll give three quarterbacks get
drafted in the no i'm not i'm gonna say
four wide receivers go in the first
round i think that three
i think sure you don't want to change
your mind again yeah i'm good
that was a hell of a pivot it was
mid-sentence because
because i'm not going to say herbert and
jordan love are definitely going to make
it to the top 10 yet i don't know and
again like i said i haven't evaluated i
know it's a slam dunk there's four
receivers going in the first round i
don't even need to study them at that
this point just from what i've seen on
tv and at the combine four are going in
the first round
i do not think four receivers will get
picked in the first round i think it'll
be less than four whoa because if you
look at if you look at a position group
that might be the best ever at wide
receiver last year was one of the best
ever and last year what happened was
the first two wide receivers picked went
25 and 32. so there were no wide
receivers picked in the first 24 picks
and the reason is because
receiver needy teams all said we'll get
terry mclaurin down the road we'll get
dk metcalf down the road we'll get debo
samuel down the road and they all did
and that i think and look
i would not bet a dime on this just if
you ask me how many receivers are going
in the first round i would say less than
four
just because i think all of these teams
are going to say
i can get a receiver
with a low first round grade with the
58th pick in the draft just because
there's so many of them and by the way i
do think there will be three receivers
picked in the top ten three quarterbacks
and i'm going to agree with peter sorry
i'm gonna go
here's the tiebreaker for me
if this new cba goes through they are
changing the formula for fifth year
options under the current formula if
you're a top 10 quarterback in the draft
your fifth year option is ridiculously
high in comparison to what it would be
if you are 11 through 32. that's going
to go away it's going to be driven by
performance playing time not draft
position for the fifth year option so
there's no longer a penalty for a team
that takes a quarterback top ten i think
that makes it even more likely somebody
swoops into the top ten to get whoever's
left if it's justin herbert that is left
over after joe burra and tua go then i
think that it is more likely if the new
cba goes through and i think it will
that uh there'll be three in the top ten
all right what's more likely a
quarterback needy team overpays a
quarterback in free agency or reaches
too high for a quarterback in the draft
this is me here i'm going i'm i'm up
here or is this peter here go you go
just go okay well i'm gonna say
i i'm gonna say
a qb needy team overpays a qb in free
agency now i don't know who that's going
to be exactly
uh whether that's philip rivers or
something like that
but out of those two have you made me
choose yeah i mean even teddy
bridgewater i could see him getting
overpaid on the market uh by by some
margin um you know the other one qb's in
reaching too high for one in the draft
you know i don't know i just you know
again it's hard for me it's early on
here in the process and the four guys
we're talking about in the first round i
think our legitimate big time top of the
first round quarterbacks from my early
look here so you know i have a hard time
saying that anything's going to be
reaching too high for those guys
i think i think a team
will potentially reach
for
uh a quarterback more than they'll
overpay a quarterback now if you said to
me right now that teddy bridgewater is
going to get
25 million a year in tampa would you say
that that's overpaying yes i would but i
don't know i know that's a good
conversation okay but but what i'm
i guess what i'm saying is that it's all
monopoly money anyway so if you make
teddy bridgewater and i don't know what
what would that make him the 10th
highest paid quarterback in football i
don't know mike you would know this
better than i would but i'm just going
to make this one point about paying
veteran quarterbacks
what team do we look at right now and
think well they're gonna they're gonna
go out and get a veteran uh because
they're not all together happy with what
they have and they're gonna go get a guy
so and they've got a lot of cap room
it's the indianapolis colts they got 88
million dollars in cap room so you say
oh well they'll pay phillip rivers 28 or
30 million
i think that that is very very faulty
logic and i'll tell you why if you look
at the history right now of chris
ballard it's a short history in
indianapolis
he does not go over the top
spending on free agents or spending on
guys who really who aren't on his team
that's why to me i think if philip
rivers says i need 26 or 28 million to
walk a year to walk in your building i
don't think they're going to do that why
are they right now being paired in some
quarters with nick foles because nick
foles is the next two years makes 30
million
and he's a very light cap hit if they
cut him after two years so i think it is
more realistic to suggest that the
indianapolis colts with the most money
for any team chasing a quarterback are
going to be more conservative in that
quarterback chase financially
and back to the point of whether or not
a quarterback needy team is going to
overpay in free agency let's just
consider the history of free agency
right in free agency out of the gates
somebody always overpays for the players
with name recognition because there are
owners out there that aren't motivated
simply by winning football games they
want to win a press conference they want
to sell tickets they want to create
excitement we see it every year it's why
the first five or six days of free
agency result in teams spending way too
much so this year we've got more
quarterbacks in the pool than we've ever
had before so the logic here for me is
pretty simple we always see overpaying
of players early in free agency we've
got more quarterbacks than ever before
yes somebody's going to overpay a
quarterback in free agency right because
this is the year to do it because
there's more than we've ever seen before
all right let's move on to the next
topic
more likely to sign a bigger contract
shaq barrett or yannick way chris sims
you go first well i'm gonna go yannick
and gawkway here i mean this is a close
one barrett though a little bit of man
of the moment i would be afraid a little
bit to throw out huge guaranteed signing
bonus type money with shaquille barrett
again this has been a really good player
even when he was a backup for the denver
broncos okay he got stuck you know
behind some really good players there
early on in his career then had a little
injury and had to do deal with issues
like that but still it's only one year
of true domination on the field so
yannick and gawkway has really shown it
since his rookie year that he's capable
of being a top tier off the edge pass
rusher his his stats results disruption
you know they're right up there if not
better than the guy that we've talked
about already but dexter uh yeah yes
decks not dex what's the hell is the the
the dn for the dallas cowboys who got a
hundred million dollars
he's he's every bit in that class if not
better so that's where i look at it and
think he gets a huge payday and out does
shaquille barrett
the other reason why chris and i think
chris is right i would say in gakwe and
it's not just because shaq barrett's a
one-hit wonder
it is because i think yannick and
gawkway is more suited to play in
different spots on the line than shaq
barrett is he's a pure edge guy and
gawkway can also play different spots on
the line i think his versatility and
long-term track record gets him more
money
here's a dynamic that we need to
consider though in this regard both guys
are going to get tagged most likely
right shaq barrett is more likely to
sign with the team that he's with so the
contract the buccaneers give to shaq
barrett is going to be fundamentally
different than the tag and trade that
could be looming for yannick and gawkway
so if you have to give up
a one and a two like the chiefs gave up
to get frank clark from the seahawks
that reduces the amount of total dollars
that you're gonna pay not that it hurt
khalil mack a couple of years ago but
you know if the bears didn't have to
give up all those draft picks for mack
how much more money would they have
given him so my point is barrett isn't
encumbered by the draft pick obligation
and could get more money even if he
stays in tampa because they already have
him and they're going to keep him but i
agree yanukong is more established 37
and a half sacks in four years he should
get the better contract maybe he
ultimately will but whoever acquires him
from the jaguar is gonna have to give up
those picks all right one more who's
more likely to lead the sack the lead
the league in sacks or lead the sack in
leagues next year shaquille barrett or
jadavian clowning i'm gonna go shaquille
barrett here but that you know you know
to me that mean it means jack diddley
who cares who gives a damn i mean gideon
clowney is the king of disruption you
know sacks are not his game we know that
he's never gonna be a guy that's like 12
to 14 sacks and that's what's crazy
about the giant county in conversation
right now he's arguably the the number
one player in free agency you could
argue he's the best player out there but
their long-term health concerns with
jedevian county always dealing with the
knee issue always banged up i mean we
know he had micro fracture surgery early
on it's bone on bone how much longer can
he last that's what's really intriguing
about that so barrett will get more
sacks but uh listen he he's not in judea
on connie's class as far as disruption
to me quite yet
yeah this is a this is a tough one
because at his peak clowney is so good
but he's missed
whatever 21 22 games so far in his
career due to injury
um i you know it's hard to pay and this
was mike i have to tell you
i i had a list of about 15 free agents
and when i would run into a general
manager i would go through my mental
rolodex what do you think this guy gets
what does joe tooney get what does
clowney get all that
and
two or three different guys said well
you know i don't know if i want to pay
clownie
not that not their team just if you're a
general manager i don't know if i want
to pay clowney because what exactly are
you getting it's not to the level of aj
green but he's been hurt a lot he's
missed time i'd rather have
barrett yeah i i here's the thing about
clowney and chris i'm disappointed you
talked about his disruption without
mentioning after play pending statistic
we're trying to get the elias sports
bureau to make it an official stat f up
the play
it's it's not sacking the quarterback it
is completely destroying the line of
scrimmage throwing the offensive lineman
into the quarterback's legs and just
keeping the offense from doing what it
wants to do and when clowney is healthy
that game against the 49ers monday night
last season was i think his best game
ever yes he was disruptive he was
chaotic and and then he had the sports
hernia the rest of the year that's the
perfect microcosm of his career great
game and then he's hurt the rest of the
year um but somebody's going to get
infatuated by watching the geneva on
clowny film and charting all the times
he screws the play up and somebody's
going to pay him and somebody's going to
to hope that they can keep him healthy
because they know when he is healthy
guys that's when they can have a real
difference maker on the field all right
we got to take a break we're going to
talk when we return about the decision
the jaguars to make a trade of aj
bouilla peter king mentioned nick falls
could he be the next one out of
jacksonville we'll talk about that next
here on pft live
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports